How to Train Your Dragon I tweeted about
this I think about a week and a half ago
I tweeted this better be the movie this
third one where they finally teach me
how to train my dad you've been
promising that you've been tantalizing
us every movie I've got a dragon that's
out of control you don't you don't sell
the training you sell the sizzle I got
it I don't know what that means
no the final one in the trilogy it is
yeah and the movies are terrific dad you
think so yeah I won't say thank you
because all I do is talking to a
microphone but I'm glad you like them
I'm very proud of them
yeah it's the last one and it's it's
real sad and someone from the movie
company's going it's very moving it's
very moving and the right one is really
Bambi wasn't sad it was moving
Schindler's List is very moving yeah I'm
not comparing there's nothing like she
lives in the
yes well guess what there won't be if
there is a how to transcend your dragon
for you will not be a daily keep just
Kali no fair enough absolutely yeah
Disney film yeah so should we pretty
loose with this stuff
you're in great shape Jay let's take a
clip here yeah let's roll a clip
it's a really upbeat it's you're gonna
love it I'll train your dragon' the
hidden worlds
watch out here
[Music]
[Music]
no no I'm not a demon I'm not a demon
see just a guy just a guy here to rescue
these dragons so five seconds Hills
dragons shed a lot oh I know what demon
writer see what no Shuman legs on lost
in it he seemed sad
tear jerker J there wasn't a sad moment
in that well we're not that we're hardly
going to show the Russian Roulette scene
on your show this is you know this is
the worst plug for a movie John Savage
and deer hunter How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world this is why I've never
been in a film I train your dragon' the
hidden world is in theaters February
22nd Jay Baruchel always a joy
[Applause]